[Musique]
et beaupré facteur de cassin je suis ici
depuis trente ans c'est un espace
merveilleux que j'adore être ici j'étais
pianiste jeune pianiste je suis rentré
au cégep saint-laurent à l'époque et
j'ai vu un classé dans un local
l'instrument m'a fasciné tout de suite
et je me suis dit à prendre des cours
j'ai laissé tomber le piano j'ai pensé
dès 12 heures par jour sur les classes 1
cette époque là je ne faisais que ça
j'adore est le répertoire me parlait
énormément et j'ai très vite compris
comment l'instrument pouvait fonctionner
la mécanique tout seul accord au point
où je me suis ramassée à accorder les
classes et aux cégeps et l'europe
j'ai fait un bac au clavecin
mais j'avais déjà commencé à fabriquer
des instruments l'été suivant ma
première année l'école c'était la
motivation de recréer quelque chose de
passer avec passion
j'ai fait les grandes collections
classées en europe on m'a permis dans
beaucoup de musées d'aller dans les
réserves
la paire barré j'étais seul là-dedans
je prenais des photos des mesures je
visitais évidemment des ateliers en
europe de facteurs déjà établis ils sont
certainement demandé m mais on apprend
peu quand on voit dans lequel il faut
vraiment regarder les plans se faire une
bonne idée si on en joue dans la déjà
meilleure idée de ce que ça devrait
donner au canada chat peu près ça lui
qui vend depuis des années en europe y
en a quand même quelques uns on n'est
pas extrêmement nombreux
mais bon au milieu tout certaine manière
j'ai des commandes depuis 1980 dans les
années 80 il faisait huit instruments
organiques
maintenant j'ai ralenti un peu mes
cartes instruments parent indiquera ce
que tout s'est facilement qu'en première
satisfaction d'un instrument c'est quand
tu mets les carpes et tu commences à
l'entendre
[Musique]
il faut extrêmement soit porteur de
quelque chose qu'il donne le goût de
créer de l'émotion
[Musique]
j'avais fait cet instrument là c'était
mon centième clients donc tant qu'à
faire le 100ème place 1 on va faire un
instrument de particuliers et voilà
l'instrument qui apparaît le cas
mystérieux mais sûrement verticale qui
est extrêmement particulier
renoncer de jouer c'est encore
d'actualité j'étais franchement trop
nerveux en concert
en fait je joue tous les jours
pratiquement joue entre une demi-heure
et une heure et demie tous les jours
c'est mon plaisir
2019 est déjà s'est remplie jeu
trois instruments affaires revue start
fabriquer 161e
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
probablement encore jusqu'à la fin de
mes jours jusqu'à temps que sa forme de
trouble
[Musique]